There's like this tone I've seen in some of the media coverage where it's like,
Hey, some jerks want to reopen schools.
And then the media organizations are like casting that as, uh,
a terrible idea and dangerous. And then as usual,
the truth lies somewhere in between. Um, so first, can we lay out the case?
Why frankly, kids actually benefit from school or need school, like schools are,
are, uh, are like a huge value add on several levels?
Yeah. I mean, I think that there's,
there's this sort of kid case in the kind of economy case for why we have
schools. And so I think on the, on the kids side, um,
one clear thing is that kids learn better in schools. So we saw this, you know,
we, I mean, that's should be sort of obvious. Um, but even if you sort of,
if you look for a data from the spring about kind of what happened to metrics of
learning, uh, when kids went remote, you know, they, they went down a lot. Uh,
kids do not learn as well, uh, as well remotely.
And that is particularly true for students who have fewer resources. Uh,
and so that, I mean, the,
the kind of potential learning loss is in the inequality,
in those learning losses. If we, you know, if we are fully online or, um,
with kind of, no, as we were in the spring,
the potential losses for the year are very, are very significant.
So I think there's just like huge value for kids in being in school.
And it isn't just learning. It's also socialization, you know,
sort of thinking about like, what is your five-year-old getting out of,
out of school? Yeah. Part of it is like they're learning to read,
they're learning their letters.
Part of it is that they're learning to like operate in the operate in the world.
Um,
we don't know that much about what's going to happen if we lose those things.
But I think we have a sense that, that they're, that they're important.
And then there's this sort of separate issue,
which is just schools are the kind of childcare that a lot of people are using.
So if we want people to be able to go to their jobs and the, you know,
participate in the economy, particularly women,
we need to figure out something for their kids to be doing during the day.
And if that's not school, I don't know what it's, uh, what it's going to be.
But, you know,
I think people have bristled this idea that like school is childcare like, Oh,
what school is not childcare? Well.
School is definitely childcare people.
It is. I mean, it's not pejorative, it's not, it's not meant to be pejorative,
but it is, it is a thing that people are using for childcare, for sure.
And I think it's important to recognize that.
Um, yeah, you know, not this extreme end, um, my wife,
Evelyn said something because she's always looking out for, um, for kids,
you said like schools are an abuse detector where if you are,
um, uh, mistreating your child,
like the most common place people are going to pick up on it is when their kid
goes to school and that they have like a bruise or marking or they seem
traumatized. Uh, so you know, like it's, it's childcare. Yes. I mean,
that's just a factual, uh, reality,
but it's also in some cases, even like a safeguard or a Haven.
And it's a place, people get food, right. I mean, sort of look at like what,
you know, what happened to food insecurity over the last, uh, you know,
over this, this last period, you know, many,
many more kids are going hungry because you know,
the school lunch program is serving, you know, millions,
tens of millions of kids every, every day. And,
and I think part of what's missing from some of these conversations is a lot of
the people having these conversations are, are, it's not,
they don't care about these issues, but they're not living them. Right.
So we're having this conversation. And like, the truth is like,
if my kids don't go to school, that is going to be annoying for me, but it,
it is not, you know, there's.
It's essential, it's not priceless.
Exactly.
And a lot of the people who are having these conversations are in that role.
And so we're sort of like,
it's hard to really visualize quite how bad this may turn out to be for
kids who are in a very different situation.
So let's see if we can try and define the impact of an extended summer slump,
because I know when kids go off for the summer and they're,
they're not doing a whole lot, um, that there's some data around,
um, the fact they forget stuff. Uh, the fact that they learned things.
So let's say we extended the summer slump by several months for the spring,
which we probably did. Uh, like, do we have any sense of, of how,
and as a parent, um, my kids haven't learned for like, quite some time.
It's like, like they, they, you have online school, but like, uh, I mean,
it's not a great and, uh, like, and anyone who's out there first,
actually let's unpack that for a moment because there are a lot of, um,
like a techno optimists who are like, Hey, um,
online school is the future. Online school is the bomb.
Why do we even send kids to school? Like online is a way,
do we have data on that? Aside from my anecdotal, um, since, uh,
that my kids have not been exactly like, uh, you know,
tearing the world up over the last number of months.
I mean, I think the best data I've seen on this was put out by, um,
actually one of my colleagues, who's an opportunity insights, uh,
and they use data from Zearn,
which is an online math platform that's linked to your Brega.
So it's actually a platform, a lot of schools use. Um, so it's basically,
so Eureka is like a standard math curriculum. And then Zearn is this like,
like online portal where you basically like kids can sort of self learn in,
in German. A lot of schools use it in the school.
And what's really nice about it is you can track progress,
really granularly because there's like these badges.
So you can see like at the end of each lesson,
like you do this activity and then you earn a badge.
So you can see like how quickly are kids learning, he's earning these badges.
Uh, and so they,
they look at sort of what happens to kids who are enrolled in schools who are
using zones. So the school is using Zearn before and after.
And they can see like what happens to the number of badges and in, you know,
schools in high-income districts, the, there is some learning loss that share,
you know, the like badge earning goes down by like, I dunno, 30%, uh,
or something in, in schools, in low income districts.
And this isn't low-income kids, it's just schools in low-income districts.
So it's going down by about 70%. So like, yeah.
So it's basically like people, I know some people have said, well,
like maybe people are, you know, have moved to other, I mean,
this sort of like technological, like,
and people move to even better systems for remote learning. I think.
No.
Your transition would be an online math platform that you are already using.
If you ask, like,
what is the thing that is going to be the most successful in moving to remote
learning, it would be things that are already on the computer.
And so I think that, that, that gives you a sense. I mean,
if you kind of translate that up to the whole year, I mean, this is like a,
like an unbelievably large amount of learning loss beyond the summer slump,
which is already there.
Yes. So,
so it sounds like if you had to just throw in a couple of numbers that you could
be like, look, um, these kids are learning math, uh,
at 30 to 70% less efficient or slower rates
than had been the case when they were in in-person schools as like a,
just a general estimate, which jives with my sense of reality.
Like if you were to tell me, Hey, their learning is slowing up by 30 to 70%. Um,
I would agree. Uh, and what, what you said about, uh,
the social operating system, my kids get in school. So I,
I was a very nerdy kid. Um,
and so I think that's mainly what I got out of school.
It was trying to like traffic God, like, what the heck is going on?
Why is this kid, um, you know, seem to be mad at me or whatever, like, uh,
you know, like that, that kind of interaction. Um, and for my kids too,
like when they're online learning, uh, it's really, you know,
they're not learning that and they just like wander off.
I can actually sense my kids and becoming less, uh,
with it or personable because they're just not forced to interact with a whole
lot of other people.
And I'm sure parents around the country are experiencing the same thing.
Yeah. I mean, I think that people's, you know,
it's sort of been interesting in a negative way for many of us to kind of
realize the ways that our kids deal with this, which is mostly not good.
Um, but you know,
there are sort of kids like who are super social for whom I think this has been
like, obviously very like hard, you know, it's sort of like just very hard.
They're moody, they're angry. They're, you know, they're depressed.
Like they just can't, can't see people. And then I think there are other kids,
um, I think at least one of my kids a little bit more like this,
and maybe this is one of yours where on the one hand actually seems fine.
Like they seem pretty happy,
but you can sort of see that there are things about interacting with other
people that they're starting to like,
do their like skills at doing are starting to decay. Yeah. Right. And then,
you know, when my kids went back to camp, it's actually like I did,
and that they were around other kids.
I realized how much they had missed that and how much, you know,
for my five-year-old like, like re-engaging with the question of like, okay,
what is an appropriate amount of wrestling to do with another kid? Um, you know,
and like, how am I supposed to, like,
for him sort of like monitoring his behavior is,
is a thing like all five-year-old boys. Like we, we work on,
I realized we'd sort of like not had any of that. Um,
and I think that that is a big piece of, I mean, it was a big piece for me of,
of learning in school. Um, like how do I deal with other people?
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If did.
Please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new one.